what gets you to that point of just like
not being excited and being disatisfied
with your life is just a slow
accumulation of stress it's not just
like hey you're doing something you
don't like what's happening slowly over
time is we're just being ground down by
modern society really and a lot of
people do jobs they hate for 40 50 years
and maybe they maybe it's not a super
stressful job so they don't completely
flame out I think we need to take a
wider lens of like well all of these
people are building up this kind of
stress and dissatisfaction and
resentment frankly and to me that is a
sort of burnout and you know maybe it's
a different phrase that's needed that's
less descriptive but I I think they need
to be looked at under the same
umbrella